first of all what was your job in the
Royal household I was about to throw
high school so I was a butler to then
Prince Wales and Dutch Cornwall there
was a small team of us and it was a fun
job because you got to look after them
the family princess women Hardy and of
course the late Queen in Prince Philip
what does that mean you look after them
what is your job like it's sort of like
a personal assistant assuming to
describe it so when people ask me that I
see you watch days and Abby or those
kind of problems and you see the Butlers
looking after the guests looking after
the mules looking after the family so
it's very much that
but also you have to be able to kind of
do emails you've got to be able to kind
of pass message on you've got to do
telephone calls you've got to run
errands you've got to act as a host when
they're not there if guests come in you
need to know kind of how to how to be a
hotel to make them comfortable there's a
report that Prince Charles now King
Charles told Harry just five minutes
before the world found out that the
queen had died how does that happen I'd
be amazed if it was that short notice
because unless she had just passed and
then he you know that that's what I
think they would have they would have
informed the family I mean all the
family would be informed at the same
time obviously that's why they all went
and tried to get there I don't think
from what I remember hearing I don't
think they got there in time I think
obviously it was only Prince Charles and
his sister and well the king queen
um so I think other family members said
they wouldn't have have made it which is
obviously really really sad let's talk
about King Charles for a second do you
think he can keep this monarchy alive
and how do you think he will be as a
king from a person point of view he's an
amazing man I mean he's like his mother
he's funny he's witty he's about
tradition he's also got a modern side to
him which is important I think the
problem that he will have I think he'll
be a good King personally because I've
seen what he's like as a person the
problem he's got is everybody everybody
loves the queen even if you didn't like
the monarchy everybody loved the queen
the problem he's got is is that very
special lady has gone and now he's got
to try to fill that role and a lot of
people will think you know and we'll see
he's doing an amazing job they will be
certain people that know will say that
it's time for change
um so I think he's got it's going to be
quite difficult for him especially over
the next couple of years because
everyone's going to be watching what he
does how he does it what change he won't
make changes you know what changes he'll
make you know this is going to be
there's going to be a lot of um you know
it's almost been in a goldfish Bowl
you know he's gonna be watched all the
time what changes do you think you'll
make nothing major the kind of changes
I'm thinking it's like they've got quite
a few Royal homes and I think that it's
possible that he might re-look at how
those homes are used you know for
example Sandra house it's a private home
but it is open to the public there's a
lot of reports going around at Memorial
Castle potentially could open to the
public for the first time ever don't
know if that's possible because I
wouldn't I initially I just said no but
then Sandra is a private home and it's
open so it's possible that we could see
some of that
um it's also going to be interesting to
see he's got obviously his own homes
like Highgrove which is where I was
based you know those are places that
were important but to complicate the
matters that Highgrove is now run by the
princess Foundation the princess
Foundation I'm assuming is now going to
be the new Prince of Wales that oversees
that and the duchy so obviously because
the new Prince Wales is the the Duke of
Cornwall so but I still think the king
will live there so it's going to be
interesting to see
how he how he plans all this out is it
true that you are like for Charles he
loves like his shoelaces ironed and you
put toothpaste on his toothbrush and
there are all these things that like you
know you guys dress him to the T and put
on his clothes his bath water has to be
a certain temperature I find this so
strange I somebody brought this up to me
about a week ago and they said to me oh
did you have to carry uh the little
toilet seat around and I said listen to
the one that yeah I've never heard of
this I what for the man I've never I
thought if you know a brilliant idea I
mean sure you know if you want you want
carry a Lucy Ryan go for it but you know
but no I mean you know I'm not wanting a
big confidence because I think it's
important that they do keep their
personal stuff but I think it's unfair
that so that's why I've been quite open
about it why would you iron shoes why
would he even iron shoelaces it doesn't
even make sense I mean why I mean it's
bad enough having tying a shot where
they think oh I've done this shot and
I've got the shoelaces it doesn't make
sense so it's completely made up and I
don't know why what I I know where these
comments come from I don't know why
they're saying them I don't know what
they're trying to achieve from it
because it's just silly it's just silly
and and it's it's just sad that people
want to kind of put things like that out
there instead of focusing positive you
know the positive things that he does
[Music]